ladies and gentlemen I bring you today
exciting news of medical advancement we
now have seen an individual
healed from his paralysis merely through
the prayer of a Christian preacher this
now will allow us to heal so many people
I never knew it was so simple take a
look at this incredible video of a
Christian preacher restoring the
movement and feeling in a man's
paralyzed hand and he did it on a stage
which with music playing if you can
imagine this is John okay he's an
electrician four years ago he was in a
work accident where he got completely
shocked he lost feeling in his left hand
he said today when you called it out
earlier someone has numbness he said he
started feeling a tingling sensation in
his left hand and in prayer he said he
started moving his hand in faith he now
has mobility and feeling in his left
hand
wow it's starting to do it I feel it
tingling I think he needs more because
these fingers are not going straight yet
but I got a lot more movements let's
pray complete Miracle tonight in Jesus
name pray pray let this miracle be done
folks pray harder in the name of Jesus
look at that do it again that's it are
you seeing this
the Lord touch them with your power let
this miracle come to pass the guy now
has fainted no give him that Grace but
his hand is moving perfectly even though
the guy is unconscious we need to close
that hand even now
in the name of Jesus pick him up for a
second
how shaken up about this are you right
now
um the tingling like if I just got
electrocuted again
but is that was that the wrong hand
there
let's
this City's good
he's good a mighty hand of Praise
remember it's not the preacher it's
Jesus that's doing it I genuinely hate
this stuff now sometimes the the person
being healed is a part of the scam
and sometimes the person being healed is
sort of a victim
and and we've seen every scenario with
this okay sometimes it's an individual
who was never actually paralyzed for
example sometimes what can happen is
there's sort of like a surge of energy
there's like an endorphin release and
you might temporarily think you're
healed you know there's often like the
ones who I haven't walked in 40 years
and then they stand up and they push
their their cane away or their their
Walker or whatever and then it turns out
they weren't really healed they had like
a you know just a surge of energy and
they could have briefly stood at any
point but it doesn't mean that now they
they can walk or anything like that
um but sometimes the person being healed
is just out and out part of the scam and
it's all a lie as as I'm sure you can
imagine and I continue to say show me a
single faith healer
who can regrow the amputated limb of an
individual
that would be something that is much
less ambiguous although you could
probably make a scam with that too right
I mean David Copperfield makes it look
like he splits people in half so you
could you probably could make someone
look like they're missing a limb and
then it grows back or whatever but you
understand what I'm saying do something
like that
um and then we might be able to talk
about it but this goes back a very long
time preachers who claim to have cured
people of afflictions and it's a Rowdy
sort of Revival style crowd and
sometimes people from the crowd are
called out sometimes symptoms are called
out and people volunteer themselves and
again you don't know if they're victims
or if they're scammers or whatever the
case may be and sometimes there's a
physical laying of hands on them
sometimes there isn't we've seen fake
surgery we've seen all all of this stuff
and of course there's no evidence that
any of it is miraculous and again we
could test this we really could you know
I'm going I'm going to tell you the way
it could be done and we all know that
these Faith healers would never subject
themselves to it but if you really
wanted to do this you could go to the
faith healers you could go okay listen
let's make it fair
give me the list of conditions you could
cure that you could heal none of them
would say I can regrow an amputated limb
that would never be there they'll go
well I can cure problems of the of the
stomach you know stomach pains I can
cure and headaches and tingling numbness
whatever get the get to actually get the
list from them of the stuff and then you
do a controlled experiment and then of
course we all know
if any of these folks could really do
this stuff
it would be immediately
praised by the medical community it
would be studied and praised if it was
determined to be real now I know many of
you will say David the Western Medical
Community would never acknowledge Faith
healing because if Faith healing were
real they would be out of a job they
wouldn't need you wouldn't need doctors
anymore if Faith healing or real okay
yeah I understand the motivation claim
that you're making
but the Medical Science Community
studies everything you know people like
to say we we've never studied the effect
of giving people high doses of niacin
for depression actually we have studied
that there's many studies about that and
I guarantee you especially the medical
researchers that are not part of big
Pharma would be glad to evaluate and
study this and we would all know if it
were actually a real thing but they
never subject themselves to it so this
can be dangerous in that some people
accept it as an alternative to seeking
real medical treatment it's often
fraudulent
it often is weaponized against people
with little financial means so they're
there in the first place maybe because
they can pay 40 bucks to go into the
revival tent rather than what it might
cost for for real treatment and that's a
problem with the medical system of
course which we've talked about
uh but let's rely on evidence-based
medicine
um and I I don't know what else to tell
you but this is truly horrible stuff